I thought I'd be there forever until the
day I did it you know it's funny I never
had a conversation with my dad about me
leaving day to day
it just kind of happened it was like
crazy to think about it was also a time
where probably the toughest time my
career was when my dad and I weren't
clicking there was a point where the
business got so big and I was getting
the credit and I was starting to get the
credit in the press and I feel like I
could have done a better job of giving
my dad more credit but I think it's some
level I was struggling subconsciously
without even realizing it that I owned
nothing of it and now I'm married and
you know Here I am at 30 31 32 years old
I'm not paying myself a lot of money at
all you kind of wake up and you've put
you know a decade of 15 hour days
360 days a year into something you've
built something and watched it grow from
four to 60 million in revenue and you've
never really made more than $150,000 a
year I just started getting so much of
the credit that it started undermining
my dad's own feelings for himself so I'm
most like he was getting wiped out of
history and it was an interesting
difficult time what it took for me to
get out of that moment was the ability
to start over
[Music]
if you feel like there is a point where
you felt maybe unfulfilled but even even
though we were fulfilled helping your
dad doing all this on the phone bill
there was something else that was there
for you and wanna chase me why yeah I
mean I could feel like me changing you
know the obsession with building the
biggest wine retail company in America
was fading and my curiosity about this
Web 2.0 evolution of the Internet was
rising and I was starting to realize it
wasn't that I was a great wine merchant
it was that I was a great communicator
and my career started to shift
at some levels you don't realize when
something's dying down when you're in it
and I didn't realize how much fire
something new and fresh and wide-open
and so grand you know I'm coming from
the wine business which is incredible
and I missed it so much I got back into
it but this whole world of like this is
the changing media landscape this is
communication change this is gonna
affect the world I often use the analogy
of a lightning bug that just goes to the
light and gets zapped I always wonder
does that bug know that they're about to
get zapped but they just can't help it
there's a there's an enormous sense of
destiny that runs through my body you
know I just I just feel it the most
important thing I think about when I
think about getting to happiness is not
so much owning anything it's the ability
to not hear anything by yourself
[Music]
there's nothing more powerful than when
everything gets quiet and the only thing
that penetrates is your own voice and
that voice isn't judging you
when you look back now at the kid who
felt pressure or the kid who felt an
obligation what would you say to that
kid now I would tell that kid to stay
the course because he's got to figure it
out
[Music]
you